dear spike dear Oprah PSDB your music
has guided me through the most difficult
moments of my life I get letters from so
many people that share their stories I
keep fighting voices in my mind it's
they are all of these letters for me
mine me wants again every time you make
something you're throwing rocks in a
pond you have no idea the ripples that
are going to come back to you every time
you make something stand up together if
one person tells their story that allows
other people to say you know what that
happened to me that's me there it's as
though I'm watching my life and the
lives of my students on screen
I could speak to people about their
problems because I grew up struggling
you're fat you're too Brown that Lake is
the first time I felt that Wow
beautiful
with you as an example I've become the
first black woman to get a PhD in
aerospace engineering I knew that I to
defy the odds - that can transform
everything Big Bird he showed me how to
accept people for who they truly are
starting with myself
your music helped me create the Eagle
justice initiative that inspires me to
want to write more songs to play them
better you lit a fire inside of us and
we're lighting that same fire in other
kids around the world it's every one of
us focused on something they want to
change we can change the world your
legacy is every life you've touched
your spike dear land
dear Stevie dear Oprah dear Gloria dear
big birth
dear Jane dear Ali dear y r-d I missed
your influence on me change the course
of my life
Gloria here Jan dear with me
there's a line from in the heights it
says wherever we go we rep our people
because of you wherever my life takes me
I will always represent my people thank
you thank you
[Music]
you